was bisher geschah sag mal michael ist
dass die platte jetzt lesbisch bisexuell
mit der frau wird die sie gerettet
ich muss jetzt auch nur zur arbeit im
hintergrund hängen einfach fucking
schwerter an der wand und nun viel spaß
beim zweiten teil dieser wieder mal sehr
dummen hilf mir folge das ist natürlich
die perfekte umgangsweise mit opfern von
sexuellen missbrauch einfach ihnen
weitere handlungen aufzwingen und ihnen
das gefühl geben dass sie selbst von den
personen die sie gerettet haben nicht
sicher sind
sollte jemals in so eine situation
kommen in der situation mut haben für
eine andere person einzustehen und sie
vor so einer scheiße zu schützen dann
macht euch nicht danach an die ran da
und durch das war das denn gerade die
kann man nicht einfach so ein kuss auf
den mund geben
unter den umständen mögliche swing auf
gar keinen fall wiedersehen
ich bin doch keine lesbe das hat die
sache die frau die gerade eben besucht
wurde also svenja die retterin die
piraten die scheinbar vierten sehr guten
tag angewandt der wirklich sehr effektiv
ist bei frauen und zwar wenn ihr euch
mit einem farben und mit einem frau
erscheint und zwar wenn ihr euch mit
einer frau treffen sollte dann solltet
ihr definitiv euch vorher box handschuhe
kaufen und in ihrer gegenwart werden sie
zu schaut eine wand schlagen und dabei
aber aussehen wie in rund der wasser
tritt zwar genauso diesem einen
einfachen trick können frauen nicht
widerstehen
morgen gut gelaunt was los wieso was los
also einfach so weil ich habe gestern
einem opfer von missbrauch einen kurs
aufgezwungen
das einfach das einfach leisten doch da
gerettet habt das habe ich dir doch
erzählt nach und die die man gestern bei
mir um sich zu bedanken bei mir und und
dann habe ich die wand geborgen und dann
war die sache einfach self und sie kann
man extra zu mir und ich glaube das ist
das ist echt lieber vom ersten blick na
ja also ich weiss nicht ehrlich gesagt
die reaktion von pia in dem moment war
ich bin doch keine lesbe als ob das
jetzt lieber auf den ersten blick ist
schon mal auf stabil an plänen
das ist richtig heiß und zwei auch schon
abgeschoben nach einer woche also nach
nador fucking woche
das ist menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend dann kannst du nicht ganz
liebe auf den ersten blick die wir ja
aber sie kam ja extra um ihr das
lebkuchenherz schenken um sich zu
bedanken
sie kamen noch extra zu unterschätzen
die komplette situation
das ist keine normale beziehung erzählt
grad ist es keine mages techtelmechtel
da ist ein lebkuchenherzen spiel okay
ein echtes lebkuchenherz das kann es
nicht vergleichen mit den anderen die
ich an der woche abgeschoben
sagt nie wieder was schlechtes über
lebkuchenherzen nicht dein ernst oder
und da kurz ich muss kurz milliarden
verbrechen gutem reichen ganz anderes
aber zurück zum thema das ist wieder so
eine sache die mir persönlich in der
seele wieder weg gut zu sehen dass
einfach all das was wir gerade sehen in
ihr sitzen rechts im bild köln
produziert wird ich würde köln max und
in köln smart köln könntest du geile
stadt aber köln ist leider auch
scheinbar ursprungsort für 98 prozent
aller hilf mir folgen vielleicht habe
ich mich aber selbst aber raus aus köln
was er wirklich ihren muss man also muss
ich kurz mal den magischen zauberstab
von jeremy schwingen und sagen stopp
generell ich gute leute ohne
irgendwelche vorzeichen von deren seite
einfach so zu küssen aber in der
speziellen situation aber das wirst du
allerdings deswegen bist auch du richtig
wieder aber du bist du sicher dass sie
auf frauen steht
ich könnte dir einfach noch mal
ungefragt und kleide ich sie beim
nächsten mal einfach ungefragt kann ja
nichts schief gehen
nach der titelseite eine ein bisschen bi
schadet nie und dann so eine story
missbrauchsfall alter warum warum er der
zweite top warum ich möchte mich text du
irgendwas dies rausgerannt nachdem sie
geküsst hat dies geflohen
die bz was von mir
ist bestimmt eher schüchtern ich werde
aber sie kämpfen bis sie mir ins gesicht
sagt dass sie nichts von mir will kann
man sie da seine wohnung abgebaut also
für mich weil es der punkt wo ich sagen
würde
vielleicht solltest dich sein weil tage
später pierre wils wenn ja klar machen
was ist denn schon wieder mit dem
sprecher los warum halt der so schaut da
keiner über diese folgen drüber hinweg
ähnliche audio ist schlecht sein warum
macht man halt drauf an der stelle und
in welchen zweck erfüllt hat
die nicht zu ihrem pierre wils wenn ihr
klar machen dass wenn ja einen
friseursalon hat ändert die lage
allerdings komplett visueller die
tatsache dass die krise die lage
komplett ist das eine beziehung wichtig
dass die andere person wissen was also
ich bin mir selber ganz gut ohne eigene
server raus oder friseursalons auf der
anderen seite aus gekommen aber
vielleicht habe ich falsch gemacht was
ich gern wissen daher wird event also
daher aus der bi richtung nord event
meint immer nicht deckt willst du ja so
schön da lagen aber meist du diesen
schlechten noten kann ich einfach eine
ausbildung verlassen
naja aber bewerben bewerben nach also
komm jetzt stellen sie ein
komm mit ihr zusammen sie zu dass die
bibel der bi wind weht schon mal also
wenn ja kann man lebkuchenherz muss ich
noch mehr sagen friseursalon
was hältst du davon wenn ich glaube das
ist die traumvorstellung in dem
universum wo diese folge sich abspielt
einfach so den ganzen tag erzählen und
dann so über einen lebkuchenherzen an
die wand hängen perfekt live einfach ein
lebkuchenherz behandler friseursalon
alle sind glücklich die ausbildung bei
dir ja das wäre der hammer weil sie
salon das ist so schön hier
das wäre der hammer ich wäre sehr
erfreut weg ging auf jeden fall wiederum
point ich brauche zwar keine im moment
aber schön du und ich den ganzen tag
weil der kompass die windstärke die
windstärke steigt die windstärke steigt
vor dass sich grün moment aber es wäre
ja witzel das ging alles zu schnell auch
mit dem kurs dass das kannst du nicht
machen so schneider
ich brauche zeit dafür ja sie hat schon
wieder probiert jetzt schon probiert er
unser team ist wenn er hier ist eine
absolute wiederholungstäterin wann
boxerin schnell küsterin kleine rote ist
eigentlich irgendwie auch frauen
überhaupt also hast du was für die übrig
ja frauen als ich bin bisexuell
ja das ist da setzt der bremspunkt der
folge ich dachte sie macht liebe
überzeugt gegen die auf die andere seite
der macht zu kommen oder lange auf
beiden seiten der macht zu sein warum
heißt die folge da ein bisschen bi
schadet nie wenn sie die ganze zeit
schon babys wahrscheinlich weil es nie
schadet war das wird seine gibt es einen
ganz klaren und nicht ausgesprochen
die leiste da ist darüber wie die
ausbildung machen wenn du mit mir
zusammen kommst dafür gibt es wiederum
nur eine einzige anwendung auf meiner
festplatte bitte menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend wenn du mich liebst
liebe bier dann darfst du hier auch die
ausbildung machen das ist gar nicht böse
gemeint aber versteht genau was wenn ja
von ihr will und sie verbiegt sich auf
die wirklich bisexuell ist das möchte
ich mal dahin gestellt sein also habe
ich aber auch nicht verstanden wohin die
kommentatorin die expertin
wissen ob sie bisexuell ist sieht man
das an der augenfarbe oder aber jetzt
gerade sehe ich es auch
ich kann hier im linken ohr zwei perlen
und einem metallteil entdecken ob die
wirklich bisexuell ist ich habe also
weiter zweifel also dass wenger
friseusen ist und dann noch einen
eigenen laden hat hätte ich nicht
gedacht und wenn ich den vertrag erst
mal handhabe ja da wird hier vielleicht
gleich sagen dass ich nicht auf frauen
stehe also sich dolby truehd topleute
ich habe gesagt okay jetzt ganz klar
warum schreiben wir jetzt ist mir die
frage ändert bier hat die nacht mit ihm
verbracht die 20 jährige steckt in der
klemme
nein nein nein nein nein
aber wenn ich die folge ist mir
scheißegal ob er jetzt auch die nächsten
gewinnern lottozahlen eingeblendet
werden ich bin raus check wie drüben
noch ein vorgeschlagenes video auf das
war es auf meiner seite